-Finally, you guys,
I'm very excited.
It is St. Patrick's Day today.
I mean, this is a big deal.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I love it.
But I got to say, every year,
people focus too much
on the stereotypes
and not enough on what makes,
really, St. Patrick's Day
and Ireland so special
and, to show you what I mean,
I actually wrote a little song.
Roots, can I get a note?
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Irish accent ]
♪ Oh oh ♪
♪ The 17th of March is here ♪
♪ The day has got me thinkin' ♪
♪ St. Patty's Day and Ireland ♪
♪ So much more than drinkin' ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ The cliffs of Moher
are gorgeous ♪
♪ If great heights
you do not fear ♪
♪ A lovely place
to see the view ♪
♪ And crack an ice cold...
water ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪ Go and see the Blarney Stone ♪
♪ And kiss it,
if you're frisky ♪
♪ Then wash your mouth out
with a giant shot ♪
♪ Of Irish...LaCroix ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ There are no snakes
on Emerald Isle ♪
♪ No creepy crawly scalies ♪
♪ So, just relax,
enjoy some coffee ♪
♪ Mixed with creamy oat milk ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Pick a four-leaf clover
hidden underneath a shrub ♪
♪ Then show it off
to all your mates ♪
♪ Down at the local library ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ To Dublin or to Galway,
if you want to see a sight ♪
♪ And watch two old men argue
till it turns into a... ♪
Cordial acceptance
of their differences.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
♪ Now, my tune is over ♪
♪ Time to climb into me bunk ♪
♪ That's all to say
this St. Patrick's Day ♪
♪ Screw it, let's get drunk ♪